nebenwirkungen die zum tod führen
schlafstörungen in nur 60 sekunden
überwinden und piratenschatz und
vielleicht nur gefaked das sind nur drei
der 15
nicholls unter reifens jedem ist der
steinkreis stonehenge vermutlich ein
begriff ein kreis aus gewaltigen
steinbrocken über den sinn und zweck der
errichtung solcher steinkreises streiten
sich die forscher noch immer das
besondere an stonehenge das alter der
kreis soll vor 3000 bis 2000 vor
christus errichtet worden sein soll
mensch ist demnach vier bis fünftausend
jahre alt jetzt stießen archäologen auf
einen beachtlichen pfund 1 über 1000
jahre älterer steinkreis wurde kürzlich
im süden englands nagatomo entdeckt seit
100 jahren wurde kein derartiges
steinkreis moment mehr daten gefunden
besonders ist der fund aus mehreren
gründen eine radiocarbon untersuchung
ergab dass die entdeckten steinen darf
man wohl beinahe 6000 jahre alt sind der
kreis besteht aus 31 steinbrocken und
hat einen durchmesser von über 30 metern
neben dem beachtlichen alter ist der
kreis von daten der höchstgelegene in
ganz süd england spuren von möglichen
feuerstellen und lagerplätzen innerhalb
des kreises konnten ebenso gesichert
werden die experten halten dies ein
hinweis dafür dass der steinkreis für
die damals lebenden menschen ein ort der
zeremonien und der religiösen akt
darstellte historische forschung
berichten von der bevölkerung rund um
das moor sie hätten sehr prachtvoll
gefeiert und wenn ein könig beerdigt
wurde
hätten sie eine nahezu irrsinnigen
aufwand betrieben wer weiß vielleicht
war der irrsinnige aufwand nur eine der
leistung bei einer beerdigung bis wir
mehr erfahren müssen müssen wir uns noch
etwas gedulden die in dartmoor
beschäftigten forscher werden erst im
sommer ihre arbeit am stein kreis
fortsetzen
wer schonmal medikamente einnehmen
musste soll der vorkommen und die
packungsbeilage beachtet und durch
gelesen hat weiß was da so alles drin
stehen kann nebenwirkungen wie übelkeit
erbrechen oder gewichtszunahme kennt
wahrscheinlich jeder doch schon einmal
gelesen dass als nebenwirkung der tod
aufgeführt wurde
liest man wohl eher selten aber seit
1957 gab es mehr als 90 medikamente mit
der nebenwirkung tod an medikamenten die
nach einer prüfung vom markt genommen
worden sind mangelt es also nicht grund
lebensgefährliche nebenwirkungen
doch wie können solche medikamente
überhaupt so lange auf dem markt bleiben
denn das ist das problem einer studie
nach vergehen mehr als ein bis zwei
jahre bis ein medikament nachdem es für
tödlich diagnostiziert worden ist vom
handel ausgeschlossen worden ist das ist
zu lange das bisher am längsten
verwendete medikament trotz negative
befunde ist das barbiturat phaeno barbie
tal 1929 wurde das erste mal dieses
medikament als todesursache aufgeführt
und vom handel ausgeschlossen wurde es
erst mal 85 das sind 56 jahre
man könnte jetzt denken dass sich die
zeitspanne heute deutlich von damals
unterscheidet ist auch so aber man geht
davon aus dass es immer noch bis zu zwei
jahre dauert bis ein tödliches
medikament vom markt genommen wird
die forscher und barry clifford fanden
nach madagaskar einen piratenschatz
einen 50 kilogramm schweren silberbarren
das besondere an dem fund ist dass er in
einem schiffswrack gefunden wurde
ehemaliger besitzer des schiffes sei der
pirat william pitt aus dem 17ten
jahrhundert stolz zeigten die forscher
ihre entdeckung den präsidenten experten
der unesco stellten das ganze nun
vehement in frage alles sei ein einziges
theater ulrike nur ihm von der unesco
ist sich nicht so sicher dass ein pirat
wie kid es war seine beute
sichergestellt hat und nicht auf offener
see herum treiben ließ ein indiz dafür
dass alles an dem fund gespielt wurde
sei die verfilmung dessen der history
channel habe sämtliche kosten des
tauchgangs übernommen und
oktober films hat daraus eine serie
produziert neben dem video content der
rund um das geschehen produziert wurde
erscheint die eigentlich übliche
schriftliche und wissenschaftliche
dokumentation sehr spärlich
jede andeutung dass der fund irgendwie
inszeniert worden ist ist nicht nur
lächerlich sondern kommt einer
verleumdung leicht so ein sprecher der
gesellschaft oktober films die sehr
empört über die anschuldigung der unesco
reagierte der fund wäre von erfahrenen
forschern durchgeführt und von
unterwasser archäologen betreut worden
in den nächsten tagen treffen
spezialisten der unesco in madagaskar
ein und werden dem fund unter die lupe
nehmen
schlafstörungen sind in deutschland weit
verbreitet jeder dritte deutsche leidet
berichten zufolge scharf sturm entweder
schlafen diese schlecht ein wachen
frühauf werden mitten in der nacht wach
oder können dann teilweise schlecht oder
gar nicht mehr anschlagen
das gefährliche daran sind die folgen
von schlafmangel im schlaf regeneriert
sich der ganze körper wenn ihm das
verwehrt wird kann dies zur depression
und oder zur blutprobe und das ist
ziemlich gefährlich drn nur weil ist für
seine arbeit im bereich des yogas und
der integrativen medizin weltweit
bekannt er ist ein befürworter der 478
atemtechnik diese technik soll es
ermöglichen in 60 sekunden einzuschlafen
wie soll das funktionieren wichtig beim
anschaffen ist dass man zur ruhe kommt
der puls sollte möglichst gering sein
und wir sollten versuchen den kopf etwas
frei zu bekommen
da kommt eben jetzt diese 478
atemtechnik ins spiel schritt eins die
sieben lange durch die nase einatmen
luft anhalten bis sieben zählen lange
einer hatten bedeutete viel
sauerstoffzufuhr atem anhalten führt
dazu dass mehr sauerstoff das blut
erreicht schritt 2 die acht in einem zug
8 sekunden durch den mund ausatmen
lange ausatmen bedeutet dass mir bereits
schon benutzte luft aus unseren
lungenflügel überhaupt heraus
transportiert wird schritt 3 die 4
die ersten beiden schritte vier mal
wiederholen je öfter wir das ganze
wiederholen desto wirksamer würde sei
training training training
diese schritte senken den puls und
lenken unsere gedanken vom stressigen
alltag ab ist ein bisschen wie
meditation durch das bewusste ein und
ausatmen konzentrieren wir uns nämlich
voll und ganz auf unseren körper bei der
alten technik ist vor allem der dritte
schritt der wichtigste wird das
kontinuierlich und wird größere erfolge
erzielten wir berichteten schon einmal
über den drogen report 2015 die deutsche
hauptstelle für suchtfragen dhs
veröffentlichte weitere zahlen über den
konsum und die folgen von illegalen und
legalen drogen über 70.000 menschen
sterben jährlich an alkohol allein durch
den tabakkonsum sterben sogar mehr als
100.000 mal eine flasche bier oder ein
glas wein zum essen einen kleinen
zigarettenpause während der arbeit
klingt nach alltag wenn man das ganze
mal anders ausdrückt ist ganz anders
drogen zum essen und während der arbeit
alkohol und tabak haben sich so weit in
unsere gesellschaft integriert dass sie
niemand mehr als droge ansieht doch
genau das sind sie legale drogen und
diese stuft die der es als eine der
gefährlichsten 1
im gegensatz zu den großen zahlen von
mehr als 70.000 100.000 zählen
statistiken gerade mal 1032 todesfälle
aufgrund von illegalen drogen die der es
ruft die regierung in die verantwortung
wenn man alle europäischen länder
gegenüber stellt fällt auf dass
deutschland mit der prävention gegen
alkohol- und tabakkonsum sehr im
hintertreffen ist experten sehen einen
anfang der besserung in den vertriebsweg
der zigaretten automaten sollten nicht
mehr so offen zugänglich sein und wer
zigaretten verkaufen möchte soll sich um
eine spezielle lizenz bemühen wie
schädlich sind marihuana alkohol und co
mehr infos zum droge report 2015 findet
ihr im video hier
ob und zum block mit täglichen
wissenschaft die news gibt's hier
klicken
und jetzt probiert heute abend nochmal
die 478 atemtechnik aus und lasst uns in
den kommentaren wissen wie sie gewürgt
hat ob es bei euch geklappt hat
natürlich dann am nächsten morgen oder
wenn es nicht klappt könnte das abends
noch posten also viel erfolg dabei und
bis dann bleibt